when you think of an american farm
you probably think of something like
this
a barn a field a diverse group of
animals
[Music]
until relatively recently if you ate
meat it probably came from a farm that
looked
basically like this and that was true
around the world but in the last few
decades the global production of meat
has skyrocketed and that's been driven
by a change in how livestock is raised
in order to increase profits and raise
livestock more cost effectively
farms like this one started to
consolidate and to mechanize
take chicken farms for example in the
1970s
the u.s had around 30 thousand chicken
farms
by 1995 it had only about 20 000
but the amount of chicken produced in
the u.s had tripled
this is what one of those consolidated
farms looks like
farms like this are controversial there
are ethical concerns
environmental concerns but infectious
disease experts worry about them
for a different reason
[Music]
a farm like this is called a
concentrated animal feeding operation
or cafo cafos are basically huge
industrialized farming operations they
contain tens of thousands of animals
sometimes hundreds of thousands of
animals
and they're often very crowded american
cafos were efficient and
profitable and soon they became a model
for farming
all over the world today almost
all the meat we eat comes from farms
like this
factory farms supply an estimated 90
of meat globally and around 99
of the meat we eat here in the u.s so
if you're eating a burger or bacon or
whatever it is today
it probably came from a factory farm a
cafo is an environment built for one
purpose
to house as many animals as possible
what worries scientists is that that
also makes it an ideal environment for
the pathogens that cause pandemics
a virus is really just a bit of genetic
code that makes copies of itself
but that replication process isn't
always perfect
they're introducing lots of mutations as
they replicate
martha nelson studies viruses at the
national institutes of health
most of those mutations are going to be
deleterious and
you know won't help the virus at all
lots of mutations just lead to the virus
dying
but occasionally a mutation will happen
that will give the virus a new ability
to be more deadly for example or to be
able to jump from one species to another
a virus can only replicate when it's
inside another organism
a host but it can only replicate inside
a host for so long
every host eventually dies that means
even if a virus does mutate in a
beneficial way
without hosts that mutation will
eventually die out
and out in the wild or even on a small
farm
new hosts can be hard to come by but in
a cafo
let's say you're a pathogen if you're in
a factory farm where you have
hundreds of thousands of potential hosts
it's a bonanza
more hosts means more chances to
replicate
more chances to mutate and a higher
likelihood that a mutated virus will
survive
in other words factory farms are also
factories for new viruses that we
haven't seen before
and that's also helped along by the
larger system that kfos are a part of
there's a lot of international trade
going on of live
animals we're sending these animals from
city to city and from country to country
we're flying them across
oceans some viruses have a genetic code
that's segmented
into parts and sometimes two of these
viruses come into contact with each
other
occasionally you can have two separate
viruses
co-infect a single cell when they
replicate they can just kind of swap out
entire segments with the other virus
and through that you can kind of create
these chimeric
you know offspring that have pieces from
the two parents
just like with mutations this swapping
and shuffling of segments between
viruses
is basically random and that means
sometimes the new virus
is a dud but every now and then you hit
jackpot and you come up with a radically
new combination
that has properties that neither of the
two parents had
in cafos viruses have an opportunity to
come into contact with each other
all the time that's making it easier for
a virus that exists over here on one
side of the world
that normally would just stay on that
side of the world to travel quite
quickly
to another part of the world with
viruses from different parts of the
world
mixing and shuffling and mutating inside
animals
humans have made it very easy for a
nasty virus to emerge
and actually it's happened already we
are continuing to closely monitor
the emergency cases of the h1n1 flu
virus
in 2009 a new virus quickly spread
around the world
it became known as the swine flu because
of its links to pig farms in north
america
it came from the major swine production
region that's right outside of mexico
city
that particular virus was able to evolve
there
because you have pigs coming from the
united states over the border
into mexico you have pigs from europe
and so you have this sort of mixing bowl
of pigs from all over the world that are
able to share their viruses
and exchange genetic components and
create this really unusual pandemic
variant by the time public health
measures and a vaccine
were able to get it under control swine
flu had killed hundreds of
thousands of people but viruses are just
one kind of pathogen that kfos are
really good at incubating
[Music]
because bacterial disease can spread so
easily in a cafo
farmers typically treat their livestock
with antibiotics
which limits the bacteria's spread and
often
every animal gets that antibiotic
whether they're sick
or not at first that prevents bacterial
disease from running rampant through the
population
but over time just like viruses bacteria
will mutate
the antibiotic will kill most of these
mutations
unless the mutation gives them the
ability to resist it
and over time as the bacteria evolve
those that
have the mutation to survive the
antibiotic
will become more and more dominant this
is how we end up with antibiotic
resistant bacteria
and that becomes really dangerous if it
spreads into humans
and so then when we humans come along
and try to treat
the bacteria with antibiotics in our own
bodies
the bacteria might not respond to those
antibiotics
one way to lower the risk of kefoborn
pathogens would be to
change the cavo system to make the
spread of pathogens harder
we could decrease the long-distance
transport of live animals we can have
smaller and less crowded farms
so that pathogens don't have so much
opportunity to rip through
huge numbers of animals but making kefos
safer for humans
wouldn't address the other concerns
about them like animals quality of life
or the lagoons of liquid manure they
produce ending kefos entirely
and returning to a smaller model of
farming would it's actually
entirely possible for us to have a meat
production system
that is better for human health as well
as for the climate
and for the animals themselves we just
need to abandon
factory farming to get that we could
also just
eat less meat after all the amount of
meat we eat today
is a recent development but now that we
know what it's like to experience a
pandemic
we should understand the risks of the
animal pathogens cooking
in our food systems it's just a matter
of time
before one ends up in the human
population
whether that happens next year whether
that happens in a decade
you know that's a crystal ball we don't
know but we do know
that we are playing with probabilities
and we're continually increasing the
probability
as we increase the pool of viruses in
these farms
[Music]
you